INTEOM THANKS FOR
THIS MORNING.
>> BRIANNA, THANYOR
>> NOWU N THE
TALKING ABOUT  THESE DOCUMEN
AT MD YOU'VE LEARNEDDOARD
WAS KEEPING THESE
HID CU
RESORT?
>> WEL ABER OF
ONE IS OR NOT THE RAID
FRJUSTIFIED.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE CONCLUSIVE AS
OR NOT THIS ITUALLY CIFD MATE
WHSES TO THESSAL.
ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS CONGRESS
THF JUSTICE AND
J
WERE GOING TO FIHAD?
THERE'S NOTHING IN THOSE BOXES
COMMITTEE AND THE
SERISES TO THE OF ANAB
IMMEDIATE NATIONALECURITY
THREAT, WHICH IS WHA
HOME.
UM OPTIONS
BLE TO INCLUDING
JUST GOING TO COURT AND ASKING
FOR THE COURT TO ECETHEY.W, CLE
DONALD TRUT ABOVE
CONGRESSAT
OVERSIGHT.
BE S FOR TO COMPLY.ERIAKEBEFOREA
THIS IPRS ENTED IND HE HAS A LOO
SSE TIONS >> YOU FAMILIAR WITH
CLASSIFICATIONU CASTING DOUB
IN
IT?EIPT SHOWS  THIS MATERIAL WE
CURRENTLY
IVE YOU AN EXAMPLE -- -
HOW THEY FOUND ZAWAHIRI.ORHIRIL
KNOW TINFORMATION.
IT'S BEEN BROADCAS
T IFO TH
SKIFF OF THE INTELLIGENCE ITTEEV
MATERIALS MARKED CLATSI.
THANTI-RUSSIAN SAT
WEAPONS.
WE HAVE CLASSIFIED MATERIALS
MARKED AS CLASSIFIED BUTTHOSE.
THESE ARTHAT ARE TWO
YEARS OLD. DY ARE.
WE DON'T KO
VEL OF BEING AT.E FACT YOU HAVE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, WHIS GOING
AFTER TH
POLITICAL RIVAL, W OWN
THEOURTY
DONALD TMPEQUAN OF TBETWEEY CLI
DONALD TRUMP, AND TH YOUHE PREVL
THRE TERIALS
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED THAT
TARGETED DONALD TRUMP.
A HIGH LEVEL OF
SPECULATE.
NCWE HAVE OVERSI
THAT.RI THEM ANL AND NEEDSDE THO
OURR IS WHADISCERNMT OT
THIS IS ATL SECURITY
NAN ABUAL GTAE DOCUMENTS
MARKED SPEALES
YOU'RE G --
Q
>>'V IAL OFFICE
WITH THEI'D BE SURPREDF HE HAS N
SECUR
>>ELUMENTSO
BE CLEAR, SEVERATS OF THAT BEC
S MARKED RMATION ON WHICH TOCONS
SPECIAL
YONOE IS
R WHAT I'M CASTING ED RMATION?
THE E FIED ATHSECOND THINGE DON
IS ARE THETIONAL SECURITY ?ERAL
>> D?
SIR, NOT?
>> DEMANDINGD TRUMTHE MAAL
COUR
ST HOURS IN
HIS HOME.
WE GIVE THEMUTHORITY TO BE
CONCERN -- -- INSIO YOU -- THEY
O HIM.RS IS RESINT HAVE TO JUSTY
THAT TOULDBECURITY THREAT.
WHEN YOU CAST DOONHAT, DO
YO EVIDENCE THAT THIS WAS
NOT A NATIONALEC? THA WA NATION?
TH I'M
SORR
YOU'RE BREIN BIT FOR MTO SPECUL.
WE HALL TH ALL THE POWERS OF SIE
THIS INFORUS.
LET US LOOK.
UGO
BIPARTISAN BASIS PEOE LLING E AG
W US THE GOODS.
WE NEED ERMINE, IS
AS WE ALL DETERMINE THAT, WA
E ABUSN  GARLAE AWAITING THAT N
.ARCLINTON.I WOULD LIKE TO SAA S
YOU SAID AUT CLINTON'S
EM I THAT .
HILLARCL AN
ATT R OUE HAS PU NGE  IR ACTION
ATRDANCE
WITH THE
SOME OF  COMMENTD
WAS IN HER
YOU'RE NOTDITRUMP
TO THE SAME STDA ARET DIFFERENCE
CTE
TRANSMSIF ONGOING
DIPLAT CLASSIFD ATIONS THAT WER
ELSERVER IHER
RESIDENCE WHICH ARE INAIN'TLY
ING TO BE RISK
THESE ARE TWO-YEAR-OLD DOCUMENTS
WE D'TTHEM.IDENT'SENTS
THE GOING -- CERTAINLY
NOW, WHICH THEY WAITED T
YEARS --
>> DU D
HAVE EVIDENCE EYRE NOT COMMUNIU
HILLARY CLINTON'S HOME.
THIS IS WHY -- THIS IS
GAANS E
QUESTIONS.
ITPPLICATION OE
HOME. JUENT NINE HOURS
HOW DO YOU KNOEY'RE NOT ONIN
YOU HAVEN'T BEEN BRIEFED ON WHA
>>CCO THE RECEIPT
TAKEN FROM HIS HPAPERS AREGREE S
ONING DATA
OFA, IS WHAT WAS TRA
TON'ER.EY DID RR HOME.
RISKABOUT  I RE TALKING ABOUATE
THAT.
OFD THE LKNN
T REPRAS CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
DIDN'T REPONYSIETH QUESTIONS THE
FORMEID
WOULHA AS AUTHORITY THE
T YOU YOURSELFAT
E ALERIAL.
AND I KNOW CNN W G, I'M SURE,U
DECLASSIFIED, WHICH ISUEHAHAVE
O SE
DOCUMENTY RISE TO THE LEVEL?
AGREE, WHEN THE FBCHOOSES THE MT
IVE PROCESS OF
INVADING A MAN'S HOME WHEN
HAVE AVAILABLE OTHERNS-CLEAR, TE
ERN TO YOUCT THAT THEY CHOOSE T
TUM STEPS RE.A GRAPHIC PEOF TH
F A
SEIZURE.
, ARE YOU YIE THEY WERPTECE?
I  NO IDEA.
THESE ARE QUESTIONS ATTORNEY
GAIS GOING TO HAVE TO
ANSWER
THE QUESTIONS NOT DID THEY
THINGS. WEREY DOING OT
ESON
THAD OPTIONS.
CERTAINLY, YOU HAVE
ING INTO HIS
HOUSE,SPFO
ESDENT BID'S
USE
E MOSTUSE VASE
OWSIGHT.ARLAND HAS TTHAT
ION?MENTS.OE
WHS CLEARANCE?GOODS.
>> THE
MEDIA TWA PUSH
T OMY FROM
THE FBI A
AND THISESN THIS
MAN FBI OFFICE
ATI THAR-1
ASSAULT RIFLE.
HED SS OATT NOT ENCOURAGING
VIOLENCE AGAINST FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS IN THIS
IDENTY >> WELL, OBVIOUSLYDOWHOY
VIOLENCE -- AND MEMBERS OF
E CONDEMI
DID AND ALL OF REPUBLIN ERS OF -
>> SHO
>> -- IN JOINT PRESSCONFER ANY
ANY LAW
CERS.
THSI THE  O
AGENTS, MEN AND WOMEN WHO E
SEG THEIR NATION.
>> SHOULD THE PR
PRESIDENT?NK ALWAYS, EVERYONSHO
IST AN ISSUE WHERE
VIENN ANER.
LD MAKE IT
T SOG THAT OULD RISE TOEL OF .
GOODS, AOR
YOU HAO FOLLOW THE